des payeurs de taxes moi j'ai toujours
travaillé à salers vous donner mes
déductions à la source comme tout le
monde je paie mes taxes municipales je
paye ma tbh pays-bas tvq pitcho puis de
voir ce gaspillage d'eau et honte et
saïda imita job ça t'aide à aimer
tadjeur parce qu'effectivement tu fais
quelque chose tout dit je le fais puis
je veux pas être cliché dos et j'ai fait
pour le public je le fais pour moi le
fait maison est fait pour que tous ceux
excessivement dangereux mois pour une
économie de voir que d'argent et
détourné puis dieu sait on s'est
toujours targué au québec des pics au
québec au canada comme comme pays
industrialisés faisaient partie du g8 de
garnison capable de faire la leçon nous
lot d d d d d d d corrompu ça se passe
ailleurs puis chez nous on est première
saison ça se passe chez nous l'a déjà
qu'on est capable de faire dit sur reçu
une enveloppe le moment donné c'est un
bon salaire je travaille pour une ville
de rêve le gouvernement pourquoi
pourquoi
datacell exploser le démontrer avec la
corruption s'est tassée et ceci dit ces
gens là ont choisi terrain lourd ils
vivent du crime généralement genre de
duo si je faisais le step aux qu'on
appelle un guide mais des feuilletons
fender c'était vraiment des gens qui ont
choisi crime organisé qui ont choisi de
vivre des fruits de la drogue ou des
fruits du crime organisé dans ce cas là
je posais la question à certains
fonctionnaires
oui mais première fois qu'on donne seule
première fois qu'on donne seul à
stavelot plat tu as fait la fête à mon
avis il ya pas de point de non-retour
d'emprunt nt terminé juste avant la
défense de la v12 envol dans un hôtel
qui est quelqu'un que j'aimais tu pour
te payer sole en italie et se pose pas
de questions se posent pas de questions
tu sais que les gens attachent
c'est la stratégie ta tâche et s'est
terminée après et c'est l'engrenage et
ça si on est capable de monter au grand
public des gens qui travaillent paient
des impôts passants qui sont pris dans
la circulation puis church est un pion
je me prenne ça ma personne zeb et
regarde c'est seul exercice de
démocratie